この方がーいやーにボウた
今バイトから帰って来ですけど
すごい疲れて家帰ってパソコンに入ったら
登録者がー
1万人超えてましたーーーありがとうございますすごい数ですよ
冷静に考えたら一番って
3つにさんほんと一番人分のアカウント0で霧峯カーターを作って遊びたいぐらい
モップセグになろうと思ったんですけどここ行きたい
落ち着いてが猛追をついて
もう一番いいわもう俺の対外の吸収されたとして
完全にリセットしますまあそう6車
ってことは今と60ように今空大津強い打撲のためらとロスは十分で一番いいわもう僕
もう
以上の僕の
ちょっと意味不明なこと言ったんですけどね
がとうございますもちろんちゃんとスター
なんかありがとう方住んで今日はー
この
すごい番号での白いココア会おう
のんねぇ
日頃の疲れと1万人
嬉しいんです
一人でのんびりと飲みたいと思います
実家にいたときれるめっちゃなんか番号で行こうか
マミーが幅てたからマミーがはまってめっちゃの飲んでたんですよ
でもうねなんかだんほうじん国はスってますどんなことありますか
ないんですかそれはもうで大バカものとかは出ちゃダメっ
このイブどこカーなんて滅多にないですからね販売
ん
うんまろやかですね
こんなに髪がないもうね完全にもうねぇ
なんか
阿部と別っていう飴みたいな
うつがない
けどムチムチした女の方が好きで多いかな
これはこのバッグが多いですっ
ヤクルトくらいの大きさで1品と思います
だけどちょっと
ちょっと祭神の動画に荒れてますよねぼく
なんか布団丸は積んで生活したり up in だって一口で食べようとしたり自慢人
がもうすぐリークなぁと思ってちょっともう結構テンション高くてうんそう議員紹介
商品紹介するっていう気分ではなかったんですよ1回ちょっとをついて
しっかり
商品を一個一個子
なんか
他の救う
紹介していければなと思います
カバイっぞ
またよろしく
じゃ
また